all right so next question is please
help me understand these two verses yes
the person quotes you shall know them by
their fruits the second portion of
scripture is Judge not and you shall not
be judged
their question is is not work knowing
them by their fruit equal as judging no
it's not judging at all
a tree is known by its fruits
we are required to determine what fruit
for instance you look at Galatians 5
19-21 now the works of the flesh are
manifest obvious
you see which are these adultery
fornication uncleanness lasciviousness
idolatry witchcraft hatred variance
emulations wrath Strife seditions
heresies envience murders drunkenness
revelings and such like the verses they
are manifest it's obvious that's a
sinful life that's not judging that's
just seeing the obvious
from 22 to 23 but the fruit of the
spirit is love joy peace long-suffering
gentleness goodness Faith meekness
Temperance we have two sets of of
outward Expressions one the carnal
nature two the converted nature you must
be able to recognize one from the other
that's not judging that is acknowledging
that sin that's righteousness
now First Corinthians 6 verse 1 do any
of you having a matter against another
go to court before the unjust and not
before the Saints the meaning a
Christian should not sue a Christian
that's what Paul is saying to the
Believers why do you go to court go to
the church and have the things settled
do you not know that we should the saint
shall judge the world and if the world
shall be judged by us are you unworthy
to judge the smallest matters verse
three knowing not that we shall judge
Angels how much more things that apply
to this life pretend to this life we
must
make decisions and make judgments we
can't judge the heart
we can't judge this
we can judge your behavior that's why
the church can exercise discipline if
the church cannot judge it cannot
exercise discipline
and the discipline must exist in the
church or the church cannot develop
holiness
them that sin rebuke before all that
others also May fear First Timothy
chapter five I believe is Verse 18 to 19
then that sin rebuked before all but how
do I know the person sinned I have to
make a judgment based on scripture I
judge your behavior I don't know what's
in here God judges that the church must
make a judgment
if you've got a head Elder who's always
late you've made a judgment
he's always late you've made a judgment
just making a judgment a judgment but
you're not determining who goes to
heaven or hell that's God's business but
you must know that's through that tree
produces that fruit that's banana that's
a durian or whatever
and you respond appropriately that's not
judging a person's conscience
because if someone had judged Paul
before he was converted they would have
said this guy is going straight to hell
but they could judge his behavior he was
killing people having them killed we can
judge that
we can't judge the heart for we can
judge the fruit
thank you
[Music]
next we have is it right to honor a
parent who does not fear or obey God how
in if so how should one honor such a
parent
[Music]
[Applause]